[Music]
all right hello folks welcome to
Tuesday
earlier astd first hey there
Benny hey narf anco anko you have to
tell me how to pronounce that if I'm
pronouncing it wrong uh so welcome to um
um I've lost track of what episode
number this is uh for working
on where is it there it is work on
putting this game
online um so yesterday uh for some
reason seems like a long time ago um we
finally got uh all of
the uh waiting I guess waiting screen
stuff hey
suiga uh we got the the waiting screen
um done where uh we update who's
joined uh as well as uh sending
notifications when stuff
happens
so let's uh let's go
here right oops that's not what I want
don't want the dock down there
uh
so let's look at uh
this
and see something
uh fix that later so
um yeah suige didn't even make good
bronze um so uh one of the things that
um I was kind of bothered about
yesterday uh is the fact that we run ran
into a bug
um for what was basically an outof
order uh out of order
processing so let's
go
here um mainly because I don't have a
good way uh currently
uh to test this uh websocket inbound
Handler so this inbound Handler is
basically at least right now uh is
handling all websocket inbound uh
requests um including both connections
and and handling the
messages uh and the protocol that we
currently have is that
when someone joins with a websocket
um so when someone connects with a
websocket keep got to keep on my toes
for for using the correct terminology
players join games uh browsers connect
websockets um and
so there's code in
here where um the actual connection
that's established by the websocket
right now I don't care about
because there's not there's no
information that's useful it's not until
actually get the inbound
message which is triggered by uh HTM X
basically sending a message after we've
connected um which is telling us that uh
basically they want to this websocket
would like to connect to this particular
game here's the game
handle the problem that uh we
encountered
yesterday was we were doing the telling
basically the the use case the
application layer hey this player uh has
connected to this game before we
registered them
with the thing that's
handling everybody's sessions uh which
is this shared websocket session Handler
I need a better name for
it um so what would happen is the we'd
inform the player connector hey somebody
joined
it would initiate a
broadcast
um which would then send through the
implementation whoever's
connected yeah
imple
um but because the person who just
connected wasn't yet in the session they
wouldn't receive this
broadcast and uh this
is generally the way I like these things
to work is
I want them sort of one-way data
flow CU I could have as a response to
this connection basically sent something
back through the websocket um and that's
fine if you're doing sort of HTTP
request response but websocket is is
just this pipe where information goes
through and it can get very confusing if
I'm updating things this way as well as
updating things this way uh so in order
to to keep things easy to understand
um it's basically this oneway data flow
so it has to go like
this and then basically like that
basically back out to to the web
socket um but if you add
it too late then they don't get that
that that initial
message um so that's what this ordering
of these two lines really mattered and
so what bothered me is that I have no
good way to test that
uh
which really there there there is a
solution uh I
just I I don't I don't want to take the
time to to to to do it just yet until I
have sort of more more websocket stuff
but it's basically um abstract stuff out
uh
because this websocket broadcaster is a
class I can I can substitute or detect
or stub if I need to and same thing with
a player connector it's really I can't
easily trigger this
because
um I mean I guess I could it's it's a
little harder to create some of these
objects and really to test is these are
these two methods being
executed in the correct order doesn't
need all this
detail right what does it use it uses I
mean it uses the session for the for the
connect
um but I don't need a a full-fledged
fully qualified session uh websocket
session itself is an
interface
um but it's a pretty big
interface and so I wouldn't you know I
could probably create a there's probably
a subass I could
create um like a standard websocket
session but I but it's really like a you
want to try and minimize
creation because you don't want to go
down the road of using something like
makito uh to provide a an instance that
you can you can test against and so this
connect while it uses the real session
for the purposes of testing in a sense
did I get the message that was triggered
by this um
I don't think I I'd need that or I would
need to abstract this uh this
connection um because in
fact
uh yeah so that would require some some
abstraction that I'm that I'm not quite
PR prepared to make um I'd have to uh
abstract this away a bit really what
it's used for is is when we send it and
again we might want to have uh we we we
want we want to have an abstraction
there so we can test it without having
to use uh something like
makito so all that's to say is is this
is this is was on my mind um and this is
where
uh code in adapters can get really hard
to test because you're working with a
library or framework that's doing IO
that you don't have full control over
that's hard that's hard to create test
instances for and hard to to handle when
when things happen and so um you either
use something like makito and go down
that nasty Road uh or you create
abstractions
um or you just test it manually and and
move on which is what I'm going to
do yeah I think this is a little bit
lower level abstraction um than
something like a a venue manager because
this is more
about uh you
know like if I think about how would I
test this
code in fact really how would I test um
you know that I got the right payload
and especially once I start having to
dispatch messages based on the payload
basically parse the thing and do routing
based on the messages that are coming in
that's where I'm going to need uh some
lower level abstractions around um
routing so this is this is more
technical so even on the technical side
we need abstractions to to help test us
to still avoid direct IO
access um so I would need to figure out
what do I need to abstract from these
things uh that I could basically pull
out so that I could have all of this
code working in that in that new
abstraction so then I could test it
properly and this is where some of the
um once you have that then you have some
of the stuff around uh output trackers
and things like that that that we could
we could start
leveraging um so let's go to
jira and what did we say
uh so we want to show this start game
button so let's go here um so what we
want is we want uh somewhere to be a
start game
button
um I think I can drop I can finally drop
this now since I know the notifications
are working uh uh and I think I'll
probably want the button somewhere here
so let's let's fix that
up let's see that's
the that's the list items
um put that
there
um we're all we're all good so uh what
do we want the button to look
like yeah pretty much a some kind of
nullable inbound adapter um and yeah any
any any messaging kind of thing is is
going to have a similar
feel um because you're
you don't want to create those raw very
technical
things um
yeah so I'll I'll I'll end up doing that
I just don't want to do it right
now uh
so yeah because I'll definitely want you
know especially once again sort of as as
the right now we have one websocket
message which is connect um there are
going to be lots and lots and lots of of
websocket messages um most of them will
be
wrapping uh player commands but but
there'll be other other
things yeah so it's one of those things
where it's where it's a trade-off and
um right now I
don't I am I am ing on the on on the
side of of trying to get uh something
working over and and it's a balance
right I want to make sure that stuff is
easily testable um but I want to use use
just
enough so we need a button let's go grab
a
button
um let's see
we'll go grab a Tailwind
button
um
buttons there we
are uh good old primary
buttons
um let's
grab grab this last
one so what we want is
somewhere here
uh what do we want the button to do
that's the next question
um so if it starts the game
uh I think we need more sequence
diagrams so this is the join sequence uh
which we now have have working
um so let's go and
create uh another
sequence no not task
no control shift n is not what I want I
want a new plant uml
file uh so this is going to be start
game
sequence um we can delete that uh
Okay so we've got um the same
actors and we can delete all
that
um so we're going to have
uh player one
uh talks
to so let's see so that's going to be
uh game
starter I really am getting getting
close to this
idea
uh of formalizing more of a command
query structure um but I'm going to
continue sort of treating these as tiny
tiny use cases until uh I get enough
where I can kind of see what I need from
from a command set so player one is
basically going to talk to the uh the
game
starter yeah Pummel
files
um and it's going to do basically a post
to the um
game game handle
start technically
not yeah I'm not going to worry too much
about
um about how how restful that endpoint
is uh so that's starts the
game um and so then game
starter will
um pretty
much hand off to the game
itself yeah something like
that
um then it will
also so it'll once it starts it's going
to now start Gathering up the
information uh of the current state of
the game
oh hey
Jonas see here I try to start early and
you're
late um you didn't you didn't miss
much uh so we query the state and then
what we're going to do is then the game
starter um brought
CS
uh basically refreshes the entire I mean
this is this is the big this is the big
thing are you all tuning in just for the
rants
um so
uh once they click the start
game this disappears
um I'm thinking do I want to remove it
from the
Dom
um but either way I need to
right so I think uh the
um all these slots will be there when
this dialogue comes up what won't be
there
uh
are basically the cards well actually
yeah so when it when when this dialogue
appears no cards have been the the deck
has not been even created yet um so the
the board will be
there uh the slots for the players will
be there those
containers
um
uh yeah the players names will be there
um and I'll probably have some
indicators
cuz
uh at this
point because the game hasn't started
yet uh players can still
join
um but I'm trying to I'm trying not to
I'm trying to like remember minimal like
what what's the minimum I need
um I think I can get the
the there I'm just trying to think of
the the the layout that I want um
let's go with with some kind
of grid
layout and then we can start filling in
some of the stuff
um so
yeah I don't think I need any any of
these yeah so it's going to be something
like that
layout yeah I'm going to prep the
board um and
then at some point I need to
display at some point the the back end
needs to tell the front end who's
playing
um and when
they well I guess I have to send a full
update out anyway when they start the
game so I'll just set it up then all
right so let's go uh let's go into the
playground oh boy we got to do
CSS yay
yeah I'm not I'm not
uh uh I'm not doing the Observer just
yet um but it kind of
is uh
I'm just thinking like I really need the
Observer because I will personally be an
observer
um so I'm not I'm not sure I'm going to
do that
yet yeah the only problem with I so I
could be a player um but right now I'm
limiting it to four just for layout
purposes uh so I don't want to take up
one of those slots and the other thing
is I don't want to take up cards uh
so I can't
uh prevent them from being dealt so
there is some stuff that I am automating
like um doing the initial
deal
uh so the Observer is is really it part
of the minim minimally playable
game hey there kiss killer
um how how many lines does it take to do
a basic hello world uh you could look at
the spring guides and you could say it's
not a lot it's half a
dozen so everyone I can recommend for
for beginner stuff go to the spring.
academy there's lots and lots of good
good guides there that's that's how I
learned uh okay so what we want in here
um we actually want a grid
[Music]
um want a grid layout do I want a grid
layout how do I want to do
this uh let's hide the
mle
um I definitely want a grid on the
left so that would
be uh a one to a 1:2
ratio uh and then uh divide it
vertically so let's see
um yeah I don't need any of these uh so
we got mxo grid so let's do uh
grid calls
um and then uh so what I want in and
then grid
uh and then
Gap
four and then inside this
div uh so this is going to be the thing
on the this side
um we want a grid Ro
uh I don't know if I want to divide it
equally by
3 uh but for now that's the easiest
thing to do so we'll say
grid what the heck grid that was
weird uh grid template rows
three so this is uh
uh so what's the height on on these that
I want um
uh I need to look at some CSS stuff on
on grids uh hey not raccoon um consider
minimal setup where game happens in real
world um
yes uh I mean that's in a sense what I'm
doing I'm basically
um not having the the code enforce any
rules um it'll do things like like deal
cards
um but everything else is is in a sense
manual so my assumption is that uh
people are using this but they're still
connected via some video conferencing
like
Zoom so let's see
uh for
all
right
um yes we're going to be suffering with
with grid stuff now uh uh so I think I
want specific
Heights
[Music]
um so this grid
rows
uh does a minmax of zero and I actually
don't want um that
yeah the hardest thing to deal with uh
so I've actually as astd knows I've uh
hosted a game where uh we're playing
where I have basically the camera on
this this is actually a game that was in
that we were playing um the hardest
thing to deal with is actually not uh
the tiles and the board and the ponds uh
and the rist counters it's the
cards so just getting the cards online
that if if uh is is actually my Prim my
of of all the the goals um in terms of
staging things that's the first thing uh
and in fact it's the action cards that
is the first thing cuz that's the stuff
that's been hard to manage because like
it's hard to uh to manage these cards
and have the people who are playing see
see them all um so I am definitely
that's in in my head of uh sort of what
I want the game to to do so dealing the
cards having people be able to see their
own hands um be able to to basically
manage the cards on their own that would
be a big step forward in being able for
me to to to host
games so does let's see template cols
order
um
just trying to figure out
the yeah I I just want to to to to
stretch out the space cuz I want to get
some some sense of what those are
um so let's do this so what is it grid
grid template rose right that's what
this is
doing your template rows
uh and so this needs to be
then um
let's gri
flow if I do
[Music]
uh for
I don't understand the grid template
Rose thing I thought I did but I don't
unless the outer thing is not taking on
the full height that's probably the
problem
um so I need this to
be
uh x m Max
right
screen what are the max height
stuff so is H screen
all right well I'm going to have to do
some more figuring out because I'm not
uh I'm not understanding the the grid
stuff
um so that'll be the placeholder for
that uh this is going to
be
um so this will be column
one uh and this
we'll represent the board
um I'm missing some Basics here
uh so I've got I've got display grid
right or no I don't that would help
there we
go so grid and then grid calls three uh
so now I have the that correct
um there we go so I was missing the grid
part so now I've got these rows where I
want them so this is uh this is player
one player
2 player
three board here
um and
then uh so that's
column uh and then what do we have here
is the action
deck
Oops I did not realize I would be doing
grid layout stuff otherwise I would have
been more
prepared uh so action deck what else we
got
um so it's action deck and test results
uh and then in this
section is
um your play
area uh except this needs to be inside
of
uh this div
hey there cus
welcome
um so we need a div
here and uh so that's going to be we're
going to want to divide this
grid
uh grid template
row why is it not suggesting
hello uh let's do four
um now let's do
this let's go here uh let's do um
I have the right order for this uh let's
do that
okay okay so now I can
um let's make this
thinner so now I can see sort of the
boundaries of of stuff uh so we've got a
bit
of um so we got our our Gap here so
that's fine
uh so we got our our decks here
um your play area and then below your
play area is
oops what do we say that's your
hand
okay I think that's is that it
um we'll deal with risk tracker stuff
later yeah uh once I have this set up
then um actually the the dev tools make
it uh really uh really nice to
see more details about the grid but sort
of that takes up its own space
so
um I guess
I could evenly space these uh so we can
put a div and then a div
here uh wait a second
so it goes like
that
yeah uh
um and we'll do a call
span two
right two
um
six three
yeah all right now now I'm
just let's go back to this okay so this
is basically our layout do we need
anything below the board no we we'll
figure that out later
um so I think that's it that's our basic
layout
uh let's put a bit of
padding that
way I don't need as much padding that
way
all right that's our
board uh so then what we want in player
one
um uh so we'd like this to be
and this will be class uh this will be
font
um
bold uh
text um
I did commit I did a copy to the
clipboard
uh text XEL what else do I want um
that's pretty much
it yeah since I have um Macky which is a
clipboard memor memorizer uh that's my
my
commit uh okay so we got our player
names um we're going to want
uh basically a place for their cards I'm
just going to display them uh how do I
want to display them right
now I guess I can just further
subdivide uh this area into its own grid
um
[Music]
so this folks is how you get like 35
divs
nested uh so this is
their uh
that that workspace does looks bigger
than the hand why is that
yeah um uh definitely stuff is going to
be be templatized
yeah
um so I I
really
uh I I have been going back and forth in
my head
around
um using timely
fragments
uh because all of the information I'm
sending across is going over the
websocket and not
HTTP um that means I have to manually
invoke the
template
um a lot of the stuff I did with
Ensemble timer was
all the string string manipulation and
the current HTML stuff I've got is also
string manipulation and I feel
like I feel like to the the the time
Leaf
stuff
um I mean I can invoke the template
directly uh and I can the time Leaf
template generation and I can give it a
context uh it's just then I lose type
information and it's a little harder to
test um I'm really leaning
towards basically creating my own
component system CU you know that's what
you do
like I looked at
um uh uh Thomas sh's uh uh view
component but he's using a different
template
framework uh and it's more HTTP oriented
uh so doesn't doesn't really work for me
either so I'll likely create something
on my own so these would be
um I mean I've created visual component
Frameworks before so what you
know nothing new
here I mean there's not a lot of you
know there's not a lot of customization
I need uh but my goal is to be able to
have components like a card and then it
can display itself um in in different
ways uh either overlapped like like here
or spread out like this
um there's not a lot
of sort of HTML CSS for that because
those are just images like most of this
the hardest part about this layout is I
mean this is not the final layout anyway
this is just where I've left my
mockups
um is the larger layouts but because
once I have the spaces the the
containers for uh each part um it's just
images all right
um I'm a little annoyed at why workspace
and hand are not the same height uh CU
it looks
like I would have
expected uh
there a min max
issue yeah it's not a Justified content
because you can see the container is uh
sizes are are
different
um that's going of annoy me so let's go
see if we can figure that out let's go
do an
inspect
so what have we got
here
uh is it lying to me because it feels
like it's lying to
me like my eyes say these are different
heights except it's saying they're both
72. 75
pixels uh somebody's lying to
me cuz
like um
yeah let me turn off the
um the
debug and then we'll we'll be able to
see
it so this is the overall three three uh
three
columns
um this is the first column
and this is saying
each each vertical
section is 148 pixels I think it's not
taking into account um this header
that's why uh
because this whole thing is 148 and so
divide by two that would be about
74 oh it is overlapping why is it
overlapping uh cuz it's h full
but I want it to take up the full
height uh so then
but I think that that's already going to
take up the full
height H fit what do each fit
um
I don't know what hfit is it's
suggesting it I don't see it in the in
the
docks um that doesn't seem to do
anything or at least not what I
want
uh so right
now for
um
yeah clearly I don't understand uh
grid for
I feel like I want the fractional units
uh but I don't want them in Max
um so I basically
want that
uh but it's not taking up the full
height
I don't understand the the fractional
units stuff um
maybe I want justify content stretch
let's try
that what was it
justy content
stretch feel like it's it's just not the
the the div is is just not taking up
um so this div is is the correct
height but this div is not taking
up the height that I'd like
this is this is why like CSS is so
frustrating for me because I just don't
know this stuff
um interesting the line content stretch
and
so do I want a line content stretch as
well no
I feel like I've got exactly this and
it's not doing what I
want uh yeah I was going to go to chat
GPT next
that's what I was going to do
let's see what it comes up with
this is pretty much what I had all right
display
grid uh
um the vertical head of the whole thing
is
fine uh the nested grid is also grid
also one fraction one
fraction so it did 100 vertical height
that's fine
I did grid temp of columns uh
yeah the item was just for formatting
that stuff that's
not that's not
important yeah okay so just changed the
to template rows
um I think that's what I'm
doing um
because I've got so I've got the the
uh this
div and this div's got the H2
this nested
grid I've got grid template rows right
that's
what it's suggested grid template rows
1fr
1fr um it had a gap
that's not relevant uh
I mean grid is display
grid so the container did an auto and a
1fr so I wonder if that's it uh cuz my
outer container has nothing
so I wonder if that's how it did it uh
let's try that so that's
um so there also a
grid
yeah I agree
Jas yeah so so that's that's that's
apparently how how to do it um basically
this
container
here somewhere here here it
is um we needed to divide it further
into two
parts
um so that it's Auto which is however
high this uh this header is going to
show um then take the rest of it and
divide it into into basically then take
the rest of it is the rest of the
fraction
um then once we have that then this
part here now takes the full height and
that's what we
want uh what happens if we remove the
Align column stretch does that do
anything yeah so apparently that is some
other thing um
so we can justify the content towards
the
end uh for the whole thing or
um or I'll just leave it but now I can I
know I can do
that yep
committed yes let's celebrate
oh I have my uh where is
[Music]
it all right uh so let's do that
I have to uh pipe the sound so it goes
directly uh out instead of going out of
my speakers into the into the
microphone all right so um so this is
our our basic layout
there
uh I think this is now good enough so
player two is basically just going to be
duplicate of of player one
um let's
uh let's convert this to sort of proper
CSS I'm I'm using the Tailwind
playground but I'm basically going to
convert it to
um uh so we're going to
call this
div uh this is a player
this is the
player this is the player
grid
um
player
container yeah probably because the
noise suppression is is uh is trying to
do its
work I'll pipe it correctly later uh so
player
container
um uh display
grid and then
uh the grid template
rows thing
um and uh so we'll take
uh so uh F weight
700 grab that and so this becomes uh
player name
header and and then we
can assign that
here
um we can do that
here and then uh this is the
um player
what do we want to call it player
cards container
okay uh then we
want
um which div is this this is uh these
are the players
so this is a display
grid and what else do we
have um
that's
interesting uh looks like display grid
already divided stuff up for
us so this
interesting so it looks like it already
divided the grid into as many rows as I
had uh
this is the all players container so
this is the the entire
column uh let's uh let's do replicate
the other stuff so
uh copy
that and that and let's tidy this
up so what's the difference between
this and not having
it it looks like there's absolutely no
difference uh
so if I don't have this and I happen to
add yet another
div then it basically just divides it as
as many rows as there are so basically
it it evenly divides it unless you
specify it otherwise
learn something new every day so if I
put this
back then player four basically says
eek
um so I'll leave it at
that Cu
uh if we ever have more than three other
players then that'll be handy okay uh
and then for uh the board here um
I don't need anything for
that uh and then this is grid grid row
four um which
I probably won't
need uh so this is
our I probably won't
group these into to one thing anyway
um we'll just call this
uh call it last column because I can't
think of a good description for
it so this is basically just a display
grid there we
go all right uh so we
can turn that
off um some kind of borders would be
nice so let's add a little bit of
borders uh around each
player uh
thin
gray dashed
actually I'd like something
uh like something that looks a little
bit more card likee uh so let's go to
tnd UI
um
think I just want a car basic
card so let's grab
that um
uh we would like a little bit
of
margin uh so let's put some space
here um
grid uh
Gap grid row
Gap uh row Gap row
Gap
um is that too
big uh so that's the all players
container the player container
itself um we should like some
padding
yes so I'm cheating here I'm basically
applying using the tailwood CSS inside
my own CSS uh well we'll change that
um uh
what do I have in my
mockup I just have a general Shadow okay
here we
go um we'll do something similar then
for uh not the player name
header um
yeah I don't have anything for
that so what else so here uh so our
works so we're going to want some
classes for our workspace and for our
hand oh it tighted up too much don't do
that I want these on separate rows uh so
this is class uh
player
workspace this is actually other
workspace is that what I want to call
it here's where I want to rename it's
like I want to rename this
uh I want this to be other player
container and this
is other player name
header all right uh so this is all
other player and this is other player
container other player name
header
okay now we got other player workspace
uh what
happened oh I didn't rename the other
ones so other
other other oh I should just cut and
paste copy being paste it hello the goat
welcome all right uh so we got other
player
workspace which we would like
um I think
also
uh granded large
um
order
uh a little bit of
padding uh actually I don't want a
rounded border for
this
um ground
that looks
good uh and then a border gray
200 all right and uh want
then other player
hand uh to also be
that let's apply that
style uh where is it
here other player
[Music]
hand uh we'd like some space between
those so that would be on the
container
um that's
it looks like these are the same I
wonder if these should be the
same here they go
uh web socket with spring um so you can
go ahead and and look at uh the code
base um it's not necessarily going to be
easy to understand uh CU it's a work in
progress um so there there are two
projects that you can look at uh there's
ensembl which has a lot of other stuff
in it uh The Ensemble timer code does
the the websocket stuff um if you're
doing this for a school project you're
probably not going to understand the
architecture is my guess unless you're
you're pretty experienced
uh so it's not um as as
straightforward uh the current project
I'm working
on uh the code's there it might be a
little easier to understand because the
code is small
um but it is using uh HTM X on the front
end and it's not using any protocol on
top of
websocket so that's another
consideration um lots of folks tend to
default to
stomp uh so B which is basically a
simple text protocol on top of
websockets
um I'm not sure I have a
example handy for
that yeah so I I'm not using stomp
because um
I don't need it uh I basically am making
up my own my own
protocol
um stomp is fine though I used it in uh
the older code that's actually inside of
of this project uh uses stomp but then
it uses view on the front end so it may
not be a simplified enough example
either um stomp has the advantage of of
it does heartbeat kinds of things
uh but for me it gets in the way because
I want to communicate directly with a
raw websocket on the front end using HTM
X so HTM X doesn't support using
something like
stomp uh so that's actually the main
reason I I am not using
stomp but if you're not using HTM X if
you're writing the front end code
yourself uh stomp is is great there's
couple of standard frontend libraries
that that support that um some people
use socket IO I don't see the point of
that I think that's you don't need that
overhead uh and
so if you're writing your own front end
then then go ahead and use stop that's
probably a better way to go um I just
don't have an example
handy I know I have one somewhere
uh I have a Discord so um that's a place
uh you can ask more detailed questions
there's channels dedicated to to Spring
boot um so I don't care about topics um
I'm kind of I'm kind of handling it
myself because
uh topics would be
useful um but I'm kind of handling it
myself um it's actually something I need
to explore because it would be nice if
HTM X support websocket extension
supported
stomp um because the topics would be
useful because uh then I wouldn't have
to manage myself the communications that
are happening with different different
games but right now um I'm not worried
about that
uh okay so let's
um let's just apply these and see what
it looks like overall
that looks good because it'll actually
be much
wider uh so that's that's looking pretty
good
um yeah my
pleasure so let's uh let's let's commit
that uh let's I think I think that's all
I
need uh
I would like to convert this out of out
of Tailwind I remember coming across
utility
um
yeah tail
window uh so let's say that I want um
that
and I think chat we GPT we can say
goodbye I didn't tell chat TPT
thanks uh display grid top bottom left
right uh it's interesting that it did
that let's copy
that and come back here and so this
class is um
is this just the
game uh padding top and
bottom it could optimize that not sure
why it didn't optimize that uh because
this is basically
padding uh top
bottom left
right
uh where am I missing a semicolon oh
there thank
you I always have to laugh at missing
semicolon it's like well if you knew it
was missing just put it
in uh Gap half R Max width 80
R um I don't know if I want
that and height is the full viewport
okay um do I have any other
CSS yeah it worked out well for the
JavaScript
them
two uh let's take these and convert
that that's weird why is this Json like
I don't that's really weird
uh I wish it would combine that stuff
but that's fine we'll take that
uh and we will put that
here oh to put it in react that would
make sense
is that really what this expands to the
Box
Shadow maybe I want to keep around those
things cuz uh
let's see CSS components
utilities uh all right let's just grab
this and let's put it finally back into
here no not
that uh into a
game we'll come back to the sequence
diagram in a minute
um so what's going to be fun uh I think
we can take out this
div
um where is my
CSS
uh there it
is uh so I want to
link uh I want a thh
ref
for that close
enough and
uh
a
static game.
CSS and then uh in here I basically want
to get rid of all this and put that
in debug is unused yes thank you I know
that uh let's see
that this still looks
correct that looks correct there's our
button um I want that to be green though
so let's fix that
uh why is the
text not
right okay so that looks good
um text
white font semi
bold uh let's make the text
bigger
yeah that's too much padding
okay there we go all right
um now let's uh before we throw in all
of the HTML that we just created uh
let's do a
commit um
so we'll commit
that uh and then we can close this for
now um going to take a break uh when we
come back from the break we'll will drop
in the full
game uh and then we can start figuring
out what uh what we're
targeting um the initial thing that
we'll want
is um once the game Stars query the
state it's going
to um go to the basically
the
yeah um
the UI
component that is for the um for the
different parts of of the
game
um so there'll be like other
players uh and that'll be um
probably want
that as uh a
boundary like
that uh so we'll figure that out but
we'll take a break or at least I'll take
a break you can do whatever you want uh
so we'll be back
shortly all right and we're
back uh so now that
um we have at least a a template
placeholder for all of the pieces of
information that we're going to
need
uh sorry just what popped into my head
was what am I going to Target um and
with HTM X you can Target IDs uh but you
can also Target
classes
um I don't think I'm going to want to
Target classes though it just sort of
crossed my mind is like oh maybe that'll
be so I don't have to also have an ID
but each player other players going to
have going to require different IDs so
that's not going to work okay uh but
before I do
that let's
um let's see if we can get this to
work uh
I think I'm going to have to change
this this stuff which is because it's
basically a modal into an actual modal
um but let's stick
in where's the browser there it is let's
go grab this
HTML and we'll stick it
in here
and let's see what that looks
like so that's all great except uh this
thing is all the way down here uh that's
not what we
want um what we want is that actually to
be a
popup so let's go figure out how to do
that um um these are
panels that's that's not what I
want
uh I want
overlays
um pretty much it's a
dialogue uh not sure why it requires HTM
uh sorry JavaScript
um well let's grab this uh copy that go
into our playground where we already
have this thing all right Jonas have a
good night thanks for stopping by and
thank thanks for some dino
dancing so uh should we put this first
or let's put it up
front so that that looks good
um so I don't need
this and I don't need all these comments
cuz I'm
not
uh see fixed inser oh so this must be
the the back ground so it basically dims
the background
um make a little
brighter fixed inset zero
screenflow y Auto okay and we'll grab
this pull this out
this is a bit over much we can just say
P4 for
this
uh I don't know what text that is so I
don't think that
matters
um okay
just TR to see where that is uh we don't
need this
SVG we don't need this div at
all and I think we can get rid of this
too and now we can drop in
uh this thing
think we can get rid of
this
yeah and so
then
um okay so that's that
part uh
let's we uncomment this is that going to
work
no how about
now
no uh let's cut this
out let's let intellig uncomment it
copy and then recomment it and then we
can stick it in
here there we
go
and
yeah there we
go and so then uh
once they press start game um
do I delete this or do I just say
style
display
none so to see it we basically displ uh
you say HTM X delete I'm not going to
disagree what do you what why why do you
say that as opposed to display
none I mean my thinking for deleting it
is just we don't need it
so why I have a take up Dom
space yeah that's that's my
feeling all right so um you see hide
less effort
uh technically it's the same effort
I haven't even looked at HTM XX delete
what do HTM X delete look
like is it just
a swap Target
replace for
yeah so it's basically uh
I will want the placeholder yeah I will
want the
container
um because I will want to have a place
in the Dom to uh show future modals I
want to stay away from lots of modals
um but uh I still want it to hang around
so uh let's
see um so what do we need to change then
here uh where
is
that
so okay so that's the edge of
our uh relative Flex H
screen we don't want
that so I think we just want
this so we want basically everything
from here
think I've got one too few divs too many
divs what's the problem
here uh no I need one more clothes
another
one there we
go that's going to be
fun
uh are the rainbow
dips uh I used to have a plugin rainbow
brackets I don't think I have that
installed
anymore I think that might be standard
issue
oh look Jerry themes is updated again um
yeah it might be standard issue
now I wonder if they're ever going to
upgrade refactor
Insight
um it's a
bummer uh yeah I got some updating to do
I do that
later yeah I think the coloring must be
but must be built in
now so
um let's put it up
here where did I put it here it was at
the top and then the game screen was
below right
okay
awesome so then uh to make this
disappear um I could just say
uh
style actually I could just do
hidden and it's
gone uh let's commit
all right
um oh what happened to my
borders what happened to all my good
borders oh I wonder if it's not pulling
in my game CSS
oh it's not able to apply the Border
stuff right uh because that's not being
processed
um let's just convert these
uh so we want to do is
grab this
one there we go so those are that those
borders
uh and
let's I think I I guess I'll keep these
as separate I was thinking do I want to
combine these classes uh but I think
I'll keep them separate for
now uh so for this it's
border let's see what it comes up
with that's fine
except I had a background where'd it
go yeah had a background of slate did
that not get
converted that didn't get
converted did I not paste it oh it
doesn't know background
[Music]
slate uh so background slate what are
you
let's grab
that there we
go uh and it's pretty much exactly the
same for this there we go all right I
think that's it
uh I didn't have borders for anything
else
[Music]
so yeah let's do a commit
all right so uh
all right so that's the modal dialog
currently it's
hidden uh and so now we can start
thinking
about so the game starts um the
information we need is who are the
players um so we'll
Target the other
players um
just thinking about the
identifiers uh so we can minimize that
um so the identifier for this is just
player one
name or player name
one uh so we got other player name one
here um and then
basically it's the same for the other
two and then similar
for uh all I
guess these will just be iterated
okay so uh so we post to start the game
um we
grab
um basically grab the players and then
we
target uh
um we need to broadcast the player names
so that's
the does a game
start I guess we could populate it
before we do game
start so we do game
start add the player name
would be nice to assign Pawn
colors uh but I think I can get away
without that for
now
um and then basically for each
player so there's
uh I wonder if I just should just group
those together into a single
component and just
Target other
player uh so then I can transform each
player into the component yeah that
makes more
sense so it's really again
render um
and there's some Loop here I forget how
to do looping in plant uml
uh those are
groups I guess I could do
grouping
yeah uh
[Music]
so
group oh can I actually just say Loop
let's try that
ha Loop for each player thank
you uh and that's
n yeah there we
go so we need a
component that
takes a player and
renders that that
box
um let's let's dive into
um what do I want to dive into first so
I could either do sort of uh depth first
um basically just render the player's
name um or I could start dealing with
all of the card decks
shuffling uh dealing
stuff anybody have any
opinions here I know
for
okay so your choices are uh and then I
need to take another uh quick break uh
your choices are full render for player
um so that that's the all the way to
game grab the player render just the
player name because that's all we
currently have um or dive into game and
start doing all of the stuff around
cards and dealing cards and things like
that so vote early vote once because
that's all you get uh and I'll be right
back all right looks like we've got uh
dive into the domain and deal with the
stuff
there all
right the people have
spoken um well even if you had voted as
you would have
lost uh all right so let's um
basically start game uh is going to have
to do a bunch of things so let's and we
can close
this uh let's do a commit
um
updates and let's go look at jira so
um so basically uh we'll defer sort of
the UI aspect because now we know what
we need uh and we'll go back to the to
the behavior of the
game
um so let's take a look it's been a
while since we actually looked at that
stuff
So currently game only has
um what's it got it's got
uh create or reconstitute and it's got
join um and we can get the the list of
players so uh the next step
is um we need our action card deck so
again sort of focusing on what is the
minimal game support I need in order to
for me to personally host games uh and
that is I need action
cards so we've already got ACH code from
our earlier
implementation so let's see what we can
pull in from
there uh so we've got
um we've got Card Factory let's take a
look at
that and so
uh we've got um playing card which takes
a playing card
definition and playing card definition
is here so these are the the playing
card
definitions
um these I think are all the cards
that we want
uh but I think I don't want to take it
exactly as is
um so the first thing I need to do is
create the card
deck so our uh default deck Factory
looks like
this and this defines uh basically the
cards that are in in the action deck so
um when one of the uh important features
of most games that are card-based is you
have the the pick the choose pile or the
pick pile um and then the discard
pile uh and
so um so the discard pile then when we
run out of cards here we Shuffle this
and those become new cards to pick
from
um and so I
treated
uh the deck as a component that had both
parts so if we look at deck let's look
at
deck so what is deck deck has two things
it has a draw pile which is a Q and A
discard pile which is a
list um and then it has a
shuffler and uh so what happens is when
we try to
draw um if the pile if the draw pile is
empty we basically uh replenish from the
the discard pile which shuffles and then
adds all the cards to the draw pile and
then clears the the discard
pile so what's nice about this is when I
create the card uh when I create the
deck uh I just have to add them all to
the discard
pile and the next draw will will
basically do all the shuffling for me so
I don't have to shuffle it right right
up
front um what's nice is then I have one
place where where I do the
shuffling so I think I I'll keep that
design because I like that that's nice
uh so let's grab Our
Deck
um and what are the tests for
that so this is going to be really
interesting cuz I it's been a while
since I've sort of scavenged code from
another uh another
project
um like once you pull on one of these
objects like it pulls in a whole bunch
of things so this one its dependencies
are
on
uh does this depend on anything this
only depends on a shuffler
there's no no other dependencies here so
this so deck we can take uh
directly uh so we've got
um create deck test
which depends on a card
Factory
um so how do I want to do
this yes shuffler is a
port uh or it should have been where is
it I got random card shuffler which is a
sh card
shuffler
um that just in the wrong
place uh this it should be a port and
this this should be the concrete
implementation
um
but I it's funny I I kind of remember
creating
uh these
factories um
I'm not sure I like
it I'm not sure I'm not sure I'm I I
like the
abstractions so I like the deck
abstraction
um I don't like the deck Factory
maybe I'll end up there again anyway but
right now uh it feels like a bit
much uh the way the the the old
implementation was deck was
fine because it relied on the on the uh
on the port card shuffler so card
shuffler
itself is just an interface so this this
should have been in a
port
um but you're right actually the card
shuffler should
not it should not right because it can't
rely on it because it's in
domain
um yeah so
H so I remember how we dealt with this
in in the Blackjack game I might have to
do it the same
way um
it's a bit annoying
though I remember being annoyed by it
before and from a strict
uh IO separation of
concerns it's kind of I mean it's it's
too bad because
uh yeah basically it it's fully
encapsulated and and and and it can
Shuffle itself
let's see so this the
player yeah so what if I if I uh
continue to be pure about the separation
then it means that when a player draws a
card the code that does sort of the
shuffling is then in or at least the
code that causes the shuffle to happen
is then in the application layer
I mean it's not
terrible
um because
the draw is going to
happen based on the user doing
something so it has to come in through
through the application layer
anyway so they say
draw Let's uh let's
actually let's dig into the start game
so uh we call start game on
game
uh here though we have to do the initial
deal so would it be
game
player uh
draw a card from action
deck yeah I don't know if it's if it's
better even from a testability
standpoint I'm not sure it's
better
um not quite sure it's worse
yeah I mean the way uh the way it would
work with the pure
separation um is when the
application says
draw uh before it says draw it says can
draw um or basically something like you
know has
cards um or it can even just say
something like if draw pile is empty
Shuffle and here's the
shuffler
um the problem is is is here in the
initial
deal I mean we could assume that the
initial deal you never run out of
cards um and then we don't to worry
about
it so it be something like uh the game
tells the
player um player draw to full from from
this action
deck so I guess it's if we make an if we
sort of say um testability is not harmed
and capsulation is
improved uh by allowing by relaxing the
constraint that that domain cannot
access even indirectly
IO um that would make this easier
so for me as long as test ability is not
harmed uh I think I'm okay with
it it is
um as long as it's not like IO uh even
though I sort of put this onto the io
Banner it is Hardware
access
um sorry I thought I was going to sneeze
uh well we have the pure
example right here in our blackjack game
so let's let's look to see what that
looks like uh so somewhere in
um
um be not in the domain be in the
application game
Service uh
basically player
hits um where do we
where do we Shuffle uh let's go to the
shoe actually do we do we do that in the
blackj game I know we Shuffle it
here uh uh we create a random
deck uh we actually don't reshuffle do
we we just we just run out of
cards and that's why we had the shoe for
for multiple
decks
um so yeah that's right actually we
didn't deal with it in this version of
the game did we do that in the other one
I remember implementing
this um
but this is the only
reference yeah and this is called only
uh here when we create the
shoe yeah so I'm now I'm wondering uh
was it uh
did we do that
here we haven't had an orange stream in
a while an orange
Ensemble
so oh it's indexing don't index let's
change the SDK don't index that
one just go
22 can stop indexing that
one uh so let's see application
so where did we
Shuffle uh we may not not done that at
all in this
one so it was another
Universe uh I'll close this one for
now yeah so that this so it's not this
one
yeah
um I kind of I kind of want to do it
uh do I want to do it both ways
cuz I feel like the the fully
encapsulated Deck with a shuffler that's
given to
it
um fulfills the
testability but does break the
Purity and the other way just feels like
it's going to be a little
awkward well you even if you go
nulli uh
you still have to have an
interface it the interface is inside of
would be inside of the
deck but you still have to have an
interface um but it would not be
externalized uh and I'm I'm I'm in favor
of that
because it's not like there
are so there the only reason to have
mult multiple implementations is for
testability so create null
would
uh
so yeah the embedded
stub yeah it's I mean technically it's
an interface but you're right it's not a
public interface
yeah um
I think we'll go that
way because then uh things like this are
going to be much
easier um the player just has to draw
until they're full and they know when
they're full they know when they their
they know when their hand is
full um cuz likely it's going to be
uh
and uh to
to action deck
draw and
then
Loop so it's basically that
uh do you what to get the embedded
stub pretty sure we did that couple of
times oh the nullable dice roller yes
well everything in yacht we did
together um cuz the old one
had I'd have to look back and see what
what the old one was
like uh so we'd have to go
back it is it is the exact same problem
yes wow that just pegged my
CPU uh so way
back
here where is it
that was a score what uh so we did the
dive first yes so we inlined the dice
roller into the game
Service uh tested dice
rolling yeah
so so this is the die
roller um
and so basically we use the random
wrapper yeah so it's you're right it is
exactly the same
thing
um so we're going to go that way because
I think that that that's a lot
better and so we'd have a crate
null
that um probably
we can do a little bit higher level uh I
likely want to
specify CU here it was easy because the
the sort of the the abstraction is
literally D dice um and here are the
dice that I want cuz I'm going to check
that these are the
dice that were processed properly and um
in the
game
uh we're going to want cards
so instead of die roller is
this this might be the deck and the deck
has a crate null about how we want the
cards to be
produced we either want want
them
shuffled or we want them in a specific
order so I think that's the level of
abstraction that we want so the
nullable uh with the embedded
stub will be
the
deck right because basically it's do we
use shuffler or do we use the order
defined in in the
yeah in internally it's going to wrap
it's going to wrap here Shuffle it um
the
uh and it will either use the the
configured order or it will it will
randomize it
yeah yeah I was I was thinking more what
is what is the what is the creating all
parameters the creating all parameters
are going to be the action cards in a
list of action cards in this order
um internally what what gets wrapped uh
is right because you always want to wrap
the
the the hardware
yeah
um so let's do
that or let's start doing
that uh so let's go here
um Bo having tdd game and tdd yacht in
my list here is is going to confuse the
heck out of
me uh so since we've already established
that this deck is a nice abstraction
we're going to basically rewrite
it um to use to use the
nullies so let's do
that
uh and we'll start out we'll start out
with a
generified I'm wondering if I want
to copy the whole thing uh so let's see
can we
find the deck test
so what do we want to say about a new
deck um probably that has cards in a
specific
order yeah this test isn't going to help
me much so let's uh let's go start
writing our stuff so let's close that
um this one we might use uh we'll close
that
and I think this we'll we'll
use in another form uh so let's go ahead
and uh
create okay why do I keep forgetting
what it is
it's oh it's option n there it is um but
not in this
directory let's go to our real
code which is down here so this going to
be in our domain
um and we're going to
create
deck and then we'll create a test for
this
oops uh and we're going to start nesting
because what we want
is so it's interesting that it it that
it pulled that code from the test from
that other code I was just looking
at
um I do kind of want something like that
but it's going to be a much
simpler uh
setup so we want to say that um when we
created
deck uh we should be able to draw all
the cards in the
deck
um as we as we've set them
up so uh
so we're going to need to Define
card uh I called them playing card but
this should actually be
um action
card uh we pretty much just need the
title for now
and this might turn it into an enum I'm
not sure right in my previous design I
had enums for the definitions and then
the cards
themselves uh but then that leads to the
title being a string when it doesn't
really need to be but we'll we'll start
there
um all right Astra thanks for thanks for
hanging out have a good night
so let's go ahead and um say that uh we
want action card we'll go ahead and
create that
class right now it basically won't have
much in it um other
than
uh we won't call it name we will call it
uh
title
um and that needs to be not in
test uh so we've got deck of action
cards so deck let's parameterize
that uh and here we're just going to say
uh new
deck it's like it's now Cody's now been
poisoned by the other code I was looking
at which is really frustrating
my my my llm has been poisoned by its
training
data
um I'm just going to create an empty
deck
actually
and no I take that back
back let's create our list of
cards uh and we're going to basically
say um
uh I think what we'll do
is I know we're going to need proper uh
action
cards so um
I kind of actually want to make this an
enum to start out
with so let's go to our playing card
definition we'll grab this
enum and we're going to change this to
an
enum and get rid of all
this and put this in
here uh
um eventually we're going to want some
of these aspects of it which tell us uh
which tell the game when you draw the
card where does it go most cards go into
your hand uh but a sometimes they go
into the Inplay or Tech neglect area um
when you play them sometimes they go
into the workspace and sometimes they
get discarded
immediately and that's what these are
uh but
um but we're not going to use that just
yet uh
and so we'll
want basically that
yeah
okay uh and then we will need to expose
title
yes just like
that thank you
Cody Okay so we've got our action
cards
um now we'll create some
I don't know where Cody's getting that
from uh so we would
like we'll just create a few cards so
we'll say
um yeah I guess I don't know where it
got draw to
from
um it it must be Uno because I don't
know anything else that has a draw two
in it that's hilarious
uh so we want action
card um we'll add a
predict uh reveal no uh write
code uh and uh less code that looks
good one has to wonder what the training
data is for for
that
okay so we've got action cards we've got
a new deck with those action
cards uh so we would like to do a deck.
draw I don't need your comment
Cody um and uh we would like to assign
that to action
card
um let's go Implement that method
return
null and so our first
step is to
assert
that oh man you are so infected by my
previous work go away uh
uh I don't even think
you uh do we need to test the non-null
version um
yeah that would that would be fine I
would probably wouldn't even need more
than two
cards um and then yeah basically draw
four times and we should have two of
each technically I could put one card in
there and I should be able to draw it
twice um but two cards might be easier
to understand
close but no guitar
predict all right so this is the most
basically
uh well if I had few I would add fewer
cards so for the for the
uh if
I'm testing that when I run out they
they Shuffle I would use fewer cards in
the first place so i' only have two
cards in the
deck I'm fine with writing one test for
that
um all right so this is the most basic
test uh this will certainly fail
and no
yes so now I think we
can feed a bit
um what do we say uh draw pile is a q so
let's convert this to a q
uh and this
is uh right because that should be a
link list
look I'm using a linked
list are there other implementations
that I should be using
instead I'm really not going to worry
about it
okay yeah so the question is is what
does this Constructor mean uh um they
should not be going on the
que uh they should be going on cuz
that's how I I designed it
um basically add to add to discard so
I'm going to assume that
uh a new
deck with these
cards uh the draw pile is empty so let's
let's actually start there um cuz I
don't want to add these to those I
actually want to add them
to uh the discard
pile I'll throw that in
there and this is the draw
pile So eventually this will
be to the discard pile
uh so even before I do
draw we want another test
um I'm fine with keeping that one so
we're going to have another test which
is
uh new
deck as empty draw pile
okay so here um where it doesn't matter
we'll just grab a couple of these
that's our
deck uh so the question we want to ask
is
assert
um and that should be is true
and we'll go ahead and create
that so that'll
fail because it's false the other one
fails because of null
all right uh and so
now
um draw
pile uh draw pile is
empty yeah that's all I need for this
test
okay so now I can go on to this test um
and I should be able to draw this
card so let's uh that we already saw
that test fail so um say discard pile
add
all cards
and then this is uh
I think I have to add that code so
basically if the draw pile is
empty so I can start by saying uh
without this this
stuff draw pile remove this will this
should actually now still still fail
because draw pile is
empty but we're trying to remove from it
and no such
element
um and so replenish from discard is
now um what did we do we just shuffled
it
right but we're not going to shuffle yet
and
uh do I want to assert that the discard
pile is is now
empty I'm okay with doing this okay so
this should pass
yeah it does
okay uh I don't know why you made that
public
now it would be convenient to have
a draw multiple
cards um but I'm not quite sure what
that's going to need what that need is
going to look like from the application
layer so I'm going to leave that out for
now um I'm going to inline
this cuz what I want to do
now is this should be right
code ref
factor and less
code um
do I want to assert that the draw pile
is
empty Cody thinks I should do that
yeah that's true I could I wonder how
much more I wonder how much more
readable that is that's probably a
little bit more
readable uh but this test should
pass
okay uh so let's
say instead of that we're going to say
[Music]
uh list of action C
card that's funny that's close you're
close
Cody uh we want to just say uh
draw
uh yes that's what I'd
like hey and then we um then we want to
assert
that draw
cards uh contains
exactly see that's where Cod comes in
handy draw end cards uh I don't
know I could just say draw cards cuz
it's clear that there's a parameter
there uh so let's go implement
this this is broken
I don't think this does what it does
list of return a mutable list I don't
think so
yeah in fact does intj warn against that
it does very
nice uh so we want new array
list otherwise that's fine
um we could have used an instream and
then map to drawing cards but no this is
a lot more clear all right so this
should still pass
I'm just wondering why oh right so I'm
wonder I was wondering why why is this
test this player connector test taking
so long and now I
remember um soft assertions assert
softly is
slow it is
slow um and it's really an
because it's slow uh and I remember
reporting this issue I have to go check
on what happened um but like this test
is noticeably slow if I run it by
itself like you can see it see the
spinner
um like it's it's it's 3/4 of a
second and it's all
because this
takes like half a
second uh it it must be um I I remember
looking into it I don't remember the
details uh but it's basically yeah it's
it's
terrible
um and I think I I think the last time I
used it I ended up taking it out because
it was too slow
uh so
uh how did I fix it last
time
oh 3.24 they're up to
3.26 I don't think they've fixed
anything this
area
um right I think what I did is I moved
the assertions to the
verify that's what I did so let's let's
do that because I know it's only half a
second but it's been annoying me all
day
uh so basically store the
game and store the player
uh let's call these
actual
player and this is actual game create
the
field create the
field uh take this out of
here
and put it here
take that out take that
out take that out take that out uh and
then this is actual
game and this is actual
player
okay so now when I run my I free tests
yeah
boom like the whole thing took less than
running just that one
test
yeah lesson learned uh I want to commit
that separately so let's do this
okay uh let's commit the rest um
and I think is that it for
today I think that's it for
today so
uh oh so uh the reason why I moved it to
the to the verify is um
if it failed during the
call
uh then it's harder then it's a little
harder to tell what actually what
actually
happened so if I do the direct
assertions here um
I mean it it sort of doesn't matter uh
I'm already doing an assertion here so
it just feels more consistent to to do
it
here and I did the soft assertions
because I wanted to see
if both matched but I think this is this
is just better
but yeah I don't think there's much
other other than
that it's kind so the uh the other thing
is if um if I do the assertion
in in this method that I had the soft
assertions before what intell will show
is that actually this failed when in
reality it's basically my verify
failed if nothing else it's it's more
consistent here
so barely sufficient
reason all right so I think we're done
for today uh tomorrow we'll continue uh
working on drawing cards from a deck um
so got draw we've got
um so what's the next test that we're
going to want is we're going to want so
we're draw already repes repes
replenishes from the
discard
um we're going to want to be able to add
to the discard
pile
um and
then we're going to uh make it nullable
so the next steps
are uh so create action
card deck
container able to
draw and
replenish on discard so that's
done uh what next is um add to discard
pile and then
uh I don't know if null aiz is a word
um the
with an embedded stub for we
shuffling is it really an embedded
stub is it really a stub it's not really
a stub it's really actually an embedded
it's like I mean
cuz it's not a stub a stub only returns
values It's actually an
embedded
fake I'm not sure let's see so because
it's two
ways uh it's it's it's an
embedded not modifier I don't I don't
know I'm not sure what to call it it's
not an embedded Stu
though because basically you give it
give it the
cards yes if I say give
me um well actually that's a good point
what am I going to use it
uh it's an embedded Stu if if I've
configured it
I guess it is an embedded stub because
when it's when when I'm using the stub
it is just returning the cards that I
configured okay thank
you I was still thinking
like I want to shuffle it in this way
but that's actually not what I'm doing
I think that'll that'll and that'll
become clear once once we start
implementing
that uh so once we nalize the deck we
will have a
deck uh that is
shuffled
um we then need uh
we'll draw a full so that gets that that
gets the cards in their
hand um
and then players
uh before that I actually
need well
so if you draw a red card a media gets
played to the the tech neglect
area um we probably don't need it until
later but eventually player will need uh
uh so once we have that we will be able
to draw
cards for each player draw a hand to
full um if along the way any cards get
automatically played those will turn up
into the technical
area
uh then we can switch back
to um
then we'll basically switch back to
working on the
UI so that'll be tomorrow uh so thanks
everyone for hanging out and helping out
as always I appreciate
it um if you want to get your own copy
of the physical
game right this thing uh you will then
get access uh early access to the online
version version of this
game otherwise I encourage you to join
the discard if you're not already there
and you can ask all your questions and
bring up various discussions about this
or anything related to to this stuff
otherwise uh tomorrow same time same
channel uh and we'll pick it up from
there thanks